لم يعد لدى مارسيا شك في ان الشرطه
البريطانيه كانت وراء وفاه اخيها شون عام
2008 تقول ان الشرطه تعاملت معه بالقوه في
الشارع وفي مركز الامن وهو في حاله اضطراب
النفسي ما ادى الى مصرعه
بدلا من ان ينقلوه الى المستشفى حكموا
عليه بالموت لانهم قيدوه وبطحوه على الارض
لمده ثمان دقائق مع استخدامهم المفرط
للقوه تماما كما قتل جورج فلود في امريكا
لكن الفرقان اخي قتل في مركز الشرطه
ما يزيد من حزن مارسيا هو عدم محاسبه اي
من الضباط المتورطين في وفاه اخيها حتى
بعد مرور 15 عاما على الحادثه قضيه
الشونريج الذي توفي في مركز الشرطه هذا
بمنطقه جنوبيه لندن ذكرت في تقرير صادم عن
عنصريه الشرطه ضد البريطانيين من اصول
افريقيه الذين تبين انهم اكثر عرضه للوفاه
بالسبع مرات مقارنه بنظرائهم البيض اثناء
توقيفهم من قبل الشرطه
التقرير الذي نشرته منظمه انكوستال
البريطانيه ارتكز على تحقيقات امتدت
لثماني سنوات وكشف بالادله خذلان النظام
البريطاني لعائله الضحايا ذوي الاصول
الافريقيه من خلال استخدام القوه المفرطه
والامتناع عن التحقيق في الوفيات التي
تحدث في اثناء التعامل مع الشرطه وتجاهل
العنصريه عاملا في الوفاه
الحقيقه هي ان بعض هذه الوفيات هي حالات
اشخاص لم يعتقلوا بالاساس ولكنهم توفوا
بمجرد تعاملهم مع الشرطه وبعضهم يعانون
ازمات نفسيه وما تم توثيقه في هذا التقرير
هو ان الشرطه في الغالب لا تسعى لخفض
التوتر مع ذوي الاصول الافريقيه وتلجا
بسرعه الى استخدام القوه المفرطه ضدهم
لانها ترى فيهم خطرا
مكتب مراقبه سلوك الشرطه اعترف بان الادله
على الاستخدام غير المناسب للقوه من قبل
الشرطه ضد ابناء الاقليات العرقيه اضر
بثقتهم فيها وقال انه وضع برنامجا قبل نحو
ثلاثه اعوام خاصه بالكشف والتحقيق ومعالجه
قضيه العنصريه على اساس العرق بين اوساط
الشرطه بغرض تغيير سياسات وممارسات ضباطها
مينا حرب الجزيره لندن